kind of bonjour et merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france ce matin
leur première question quels sont les
enjeux de ce scrutin
bonjour il est le premier enjeu en fait
assez de voir quelle sera la réponse de
l'électorat à russie unie pour la
gestion du coc vide qui a été mise en
place et surtout pas tellement sur le
plan sanitaire mais surtout pour tout ce
qui est autour c'est pour tous la
question économique et social puisque
l'impact sur l'économie nationale
l'impact sur le portefeuille des gens
sur les conditions de vie sur les
conditions de travail est importante et
on va voir c'est une sorte de test aussi
devoir commander les gens réagissent mal
à ça alors c'est la première élection
depuis la réforme de la constitution en
russie est ce qu'on peut dire que
finalement avec ces élections la chambre
basse du parlement ouvre un nouveau
chapitre de son histoire on parle
justement de cette puissance c'est
arrive en force de russie unie est ce
que les voilà le le positionnement les
forces boutin va vous changer
il y a peu de chances pour qu'il y ait
un remaniement profond du paysage
politique en russie parce qu'il est
quand même assez stable tout d'abord
parce qu'objectivement
lorsqu'il ya une vie politique a s'est
établi qui est normalisée en quelque
sorte on ne peut pas avoir 50 parties
qu'ils soient représentés dans ce cas là
le pays d' absolument ingouvernable
c'est plus sain ce qui est un signe
d'instabilité et de crise qu un signe
positif
ensuite a donc si vous voulez je ne
pense pas qu'il y ait un changement
fondamental de la politique puisque
la ligne néo libérale est confirmée avec
un dea accents sociaux pour maintenir
une certaine stabilité sociale ça je ne
pense pas que ce soit remis en cause a
est ce qu'il y aura l'arrivée de
nouveaux partis la question se pose de
savoir effectivement avec lille et arras
hier
ah le parti de me ronald russie juste je
prends en france s est traduit et à ldpr
quelles seront leurs scores pour les
c'est peut-être la place à l'arrivée
d'un cinquième partie mais
fondamentalement ça ne changera pas la
ligne générale le premier parti
d'opposition restent les communistes qui
ont
une position assez contestataires sur
tout ce qui est la vaccination
obligatoire defacto sur l'enseignement à
distance surtout ces questions société
qui toucha mais ils n'ont pas le poids
que l'on peut attendre de cette ligue
contestataires aussi pour des raisons
historiques évidentes comme les partis
libéraux eux mêmes ne peuvent pas
revenir en force à la douma également
pour des raisons historiques et aux
années 90 donc il a une certaine
stabilité qui a été atteint et qui
représente globalement peu près ce que
pense la population donc ensuite le
haut quelle mesure si vous voulez la
réforme concessionnels à réellement
changer le fonctionnement du parlement
ça je pense que c'est plus une question
d'hommes qu'une question de règles c'est
à dire que si les députés réellement
continue à faire évoluer leur poids
politique à prendre conscience de
l'importance
de l'institution qui représente du fait
qu'ils représentent réellement
la volonté populaire c'est-à-dire que
leur légitimité bien du bas dans ce cas
là effectivement leur poids
objectivement va augmenter que ce qu'ils
ont plus de capacité de contrôle de
l'action de l'exécutif
vous l'avez dit les députés qui
représentent le peuple aujourd'hui
quelles sont les préoccupations des
citoyens
je pense qu'en russie comme partout la
population a été très fortement secoué
par la gestion de la crise du coc vide
la société a été pas mal déstabiliser
l'économie a été perturbée donc un les
attentes des gens sont des attentes qui
sont très simples ils veulent plus de
stabilité sociale plus de vision à long
terme ils veulent une sécurité
économique c'est-à-dire qu'ils veulent
avant tout pouvoir vivre en fait sans se
poser de questions politiques qui
veulent pouvoir s'occuper de leur vie
donc avoir un salaire qui est stable et
qui augmente et à ne pas avoir
d'inquiétude quant à leurs activités
professionnelles savoir que les enfants
pour pouvoir aller à l'école sans se
demander à quel moment ils vont être
envoyés à l'école est planté devant un
ordinateur donc ce sont je pense les
mêmes attentes qu'à peu près partout
actuellement puisque le problème plus
global merci beaucoup en tout cas karine
béchade wolof quoi d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur invité à l'université d'état
de moscou